but
i i feel like the responsibility that
you carry
that i carry this is where joe
rogan generally removes himself from
being
i'm just a comedian this idea of i'm
just a comedian i'll do that
but at this moment in history
like history literally can pivot on the
awards
of a tattooed
ripped 50-year-old you know comedian
and i think the same is true with you
okay well
i'm interested and i care speaking of
lyrics
uh you know there are many here among us
who feel that life is but a joke
that's not us the hour is getting late
that's not us
in the song the the joker and the thief
are on opposite sides of jesus having
this conversation over jesus
you and i we've been through that that's
not our fate that's somebody else's fate
to
throw spit balls at the internet that's
not your fate you're an earnest guy
you're filled with love you're getting
the most amazing podcast guess you're
right over the internet this is the
point i'm trying to make that you're
saying i'm i'm
just a grandpa i don't know the internet
no i'm telling you you're going to get
bigger and then you're going to get cut
down
you're going to keep ascending for a
while lex and then you're saying and
naturally
i'm telling you i watch the same process
people get up to a certain level
and one of the things that's going on in
my opinion with joe rogan
is is that when joe rogan starts to talk
about
his misgivings about joe biden you know
in a way that
you find at any bar in america
cognitive decline in a 77 year old who's
about to be 78
i believe in november we have never had
anything remotely as insane as a 78 year
old person
slated to win the white house and you're
saying when that idea
that is being communicated is there
something that's about the disc
concept you talk about the system
naturally some bad thing happens to joe
or one of joe's close associates
the ability to destroy people who become
inconvenient
has been documented this is what we
have done in the past whether we are
doing it now we don't know because we
are not doing this church
church committee to in order to know
whether or not you are currently
destroying american citizens as we did
in the past as we have documented as we
found out
in 1976 the federal government destroyed
americans who had political
beliefs that the government didn't want
to continue and i don't know whether you
are grasping that one interpretation of
why john stewart
and why joe rogan why bill maher all
these people
to some extent hide behind it's a joke
yeah
it's because they're trying to find a
protected class
is there some place i can stand and
speak the truth
which does not result in my being
garbage collected
interesting i i guess you're right my
intuition is you can stand
as you gain more power you can stand
you yeah there's a photo for joe rogan
right now i mean i i've talked about it
for a few years now
people did not understand how big that
program was people didn't understand
long-form podcasting i was derided
by people who i think of as being very
shrewd
for believing in these podcasts as a
major force
and most of the people who derided me
said wow did i not get things
it's like if you started to propose
you know you wanted to do the sopranos
in the era
of 30-minute sitcoms um
like you don't get it man the american
people they're not interested in these
long plot storylines
that's your weird thing nobody cares
dude everybody just wants short
fast memorable and like okay so
if you do that you totally miss the
opportunity and you know the savvy
people used to say
kid let me tell you nobody ever lost a
dime underestimating the
intelligence of the american people well
that was totally wrong because they
didn't calculate opportunity costs
i've been talking about the problem of
of joe for a long time
the problem is is that when the system
wakes up they're going to want to
control it
and they're different they come up with
new different mechanisms of doing that
i guess one interesting one is cancel
culture
well look at the number of people around
joe who they've come after since they've
realized that joe is really big
joey diaz brian cowan
um crystalia
now i'm not saying that those are all
related but i do notice that
there are at least correlations between
when joe says something when something
bad happens in joe's universe
it's easier for me to believe that
that's happening
when it's happening around joe himself
yeah but i'm worried about my friend
yeah and i don't necessarily want to
push him towards being more if he
doesn't want it
because i don't think i don't want to i
don't want to conscript people he's got
a great life he's got a great situation
he's done a huge service
thank god do you know yeah like
how much do i owe joe just for what he's
done for you to say nothing of what he's
done for me
or for brett or for sam or any of these
people
and you know i'd like to think that we
all try to give back
but i'm worried about joe he's not
worried
one of the inspiring things about joe
yeah
is i mean he's in this war alone
and the way he fights the war is by just
enjoying life well that's his thing as
long as he stays close
to things that he loves and being you
know one of the things he's honest about
his drug use
he loves to hunt so he's just he does a
certain amount of
like semi-vice signaling up front
and then you just also know him this is
why every time they try to take him down
you use the n-word you know it's like
unfortunately everybody knows who joe is
and he yes he he doesn't act
as if he went to a fancy finishing
school
right that's not his energy the fact
that you've got some super smart guy who
always pretends to be a meathead
just like you know yeah it's like hey
i'm a comedian like all these defenses
and disguises okay you've got this super
smart guy
who um he's admitted to most of the
things that
you know you can you can take him down
for him because everybody's been
effectively in his den or his basement
think about that studio as his basement
people have hung out with joe so many
hours that you can't tell them something
about joe or they're going to say wow
i'm going to believe the new york times
and not
the hundreds of hours i've spent on the
joe rogan experience but the cool thing
is that this is what inspires me is that
the way he's waging war against the
system
is just by being a good person and and
talking enough hours in a week
where that message like bleeds
throughout the words
yeah and the gaps between and that
that's so inspiring to me that
the good people can win by just being
good and
and he's kind and he's tough and he also
he's no pushover no i i always worry a
little bit when i sit down
in that chair you still get scared that
he'll call you on some kind of [ __ ]
that you weren't even aware of
no it the first time i was on the show
the energy wasn't great between us
and it was in a sober october situation
so i think i hadn't understood that and
maybe our egos got a little bit off
um i don't know i mean i
i i was having fun but
maybe it was just too complicated life
forms getting to know each other the
first one
was probably um
yeah that made me a little nervous for
the future
but then you know joe and i become
friends although sometimes we have
miscommunications like on yom kippur
i i texted him and i said joe you know i
i want to apologize
for uh ways i've let you down as a
friend that haven't been there for you
and
appreciate everything you've done for me
also like i get this text back
like what the [ __ ] is your problem
you're great dude
i don't know what bad place you're in
but cheer up it's like joe
don't you have any jews in your life to
apologize for
what they've done he was just like dude
have you lost your mind what the hell's
gotten into you
you